[Musique]
j'adore la rage les moulages sont
arrêtés sur tous les moulins à vent les
moulins à vent sont tous tombés
maintenant pour quelle raison je
travaille moi c'était juste à dire les
meuniers il arrêtait embrasser tous les
médias y meurent les moulins il à
adoucir et alors ils sont plus
entretenues waldhambach vais tout ce qui
est la cause de ça on est munie depuis
combien de temps dans votre famille
depuis des 780 n'avais pas à me
demandera haraway toujours à coquelles
je crois que mon arrière grand père de
manier
ikea moment là
oui qu'est-ce que ça représente pour moi
c'est doux c'est tout c'est toute la vie
c'est une vie ça parce que l'on
travaille regardez aujourd'hui vous êtes
avec bob on travaille avec l'air il
travaille avec l'air peut-il y apprenait
harcèlement qui louent en appui des
ronds peut plus respirer un peu puis
travailler on peut plus rien faire en
meurent là lui c'est la même chose qui
peut plus il n'y a pas de vent il peut
pas renvoyer il est mort
[Musique]
c'est un compagnon
vous aimez d'abord je voulais mais
autrement sa vision sans maintien sont
occupera audio j'ai un bon du parti soit
en vigie à loi s'il est bien c'est bien
stable quand il ya du vent s'il est bien
au vent naturellement et le matin et
qu'il faut plus souvent ça ça arrivait
en tempête on l'entend on a le bruit
dans vingt jours le bruit du vent dans
les oreilles même en dormant
l'entente dans la fenêtre dans la poche
qu'est-ce que ça présente au moulin pour
toi tu as une chose très grande et
vieille
[Musique]
c'est important à meunier dans une
région dans un pays où maintenant va non
c'est fini maintenant à pas parce que
c'est tabou l'avancé c'est parce que
c'est plutôt un monument historique
bientôt j'aimerais faire ce métier oui
pourquoi pas parce que je pourrai
conservez le moulin et le faire tourner
pour quelle raison à votre avis on a
abandonné complètement le pin naturel le
pen quand on savait en voiture du plus
blanc plus blanc alors après on a
commencé à m de quoi dedans pour
blanchir la farine ont commencé par aj
pads de cuivre on avait droit 0 1 0 0 1%
en mai dans l'appareil pour faire la
file plus blanche d'après maintenant
d'après c'est le boulanger qui il mais
aussi prendre du pain blanc puis leur
pétrin méthane et que tout cela c'est
plus ça seul appareil n'est plus
travailler dans l'impasse entre calama
et lorsque tu as l'occasion de manger à
l'école ou ailleurs d'une pincée de la
baguette
ah oui et chez moi c'est du pain de
coquelles qu'est ce que tu en penses
que c'est bien d'avoir
vous conservez du 1
ap un haut non non non non non c'est
pareil on vicois envies ses tubes one
est heureux de vivre avec ce qu'on vit
revêt
ils annonceront la s'appelle michel
[Musique]